many of us are also trying to be like
the teammates at Forest Lake thinking
about giving to those in need as we
begin this Thanksgiving week Americans
donated more than four hundred billion
dollars to charity last year that's a
record high
unfortunately giving also puts people at
risk for potential scams Lea Gallagher
is Fortune magazine senior editor at
large good morning great to be here
happy early Thanksgiving thank you so in
the aftermath of these wildfires for
example people want to give but how do
they know to give to the right place
well you have to be really careful
especially after natural disasters we've
really that's exactly when you see fraud
strike there's a lot of opportunists out
there who will spring up with charities
that sound really legitimate but aren't
so you have to be really careful and
there's an incredible urge this is
called episodic giving it doesn't impact
other giving people it just strikes at
their heartstrings for obvious reasons
and it's so easy to give online these
days so you really want to look and make
sure that these are real 501 C 3
organizations you can look to charity
you're thinking of up on Charity
Navigator or an other ratings agencies
those are very very good at really
letting you know they're legit sometimes
you might need their employee
identification number E I n but you
should be able to get that so that's one
thing to keep it that's the most
important thing to keep in mind and what
are some of the questions that people
should be asking these charities if
they're thinking about donating you know
you ask them what is your mission if
they can't answer that question that's a
real red flag why are you doing this
what's your history you know those are
the things she should ask me you should
also ask yourself what do I want to get
you know what means the most to me this
is your money I mean obviously if you're
donating to a disaster you just want to
use when it gives Orillia but you say
you say nothing is better than cash
because you look at people have been
burned out of their homes you think I
have all these clothes on my using or
shoes or items and you think that sounds
good but it's impractical yes what what
these charities need most above
everything else is cash so your clothes
are great for the local goodwill there's
lots of places you can do lots of things
you can do with that but your money is
what they need because think about it
sometimes I mean the volleyball team is
is a different story they were giving to
the local opposing team of so lovely but
sometimes the distribution channels in
the case of a natural disaster are
totally upended so your stuff might not
even be able to get there might not
exactly what's needed you may have men's
clothes named Eenie women's clothes cash
money is everything even 5 or 10 dollars
we know that the Internet can magnify
giving so every little bit counts but
cash is better than anything else what's
the best way to make an impact this
holiday season the best certain make an
impact is you know really think about
what means a lot to you in addition to
disaster giving we do think that regular
giving is going to be up the economy is
doing well there is a sense of people
giving gifts with purpose so that is you
know people are giving donations as
gifts
think about what means something to use
some people advise a strategy of decide
what you're gonna give throughout the
year you should give throughout the year
and then make sort of buckets like I'm
gonna give this much to something that
really helps change the world I'm gonna
give this much to something in my local
community because that really impacts
you know the people around you and then
you always have to reserve some for the
people in your office who are running
marathons and everything chart the
graphic that we just showed number three
random favors well that's the random
favorites exactly those that up but I
love to really make sure that when
someone comes to me I can no problem I
give to every person in my office there
but is doing something like that because
it's great you want to support it but
you just put that in one of your buckets
do you have a marathon in your future oh
gosh I don't I went and looked at the
new every time I watch the New York
Marathon I'm like maybe maybe next year
fire maybe yeah I did bathroom special
one once but not a marathon will
contribute
that's exactly really funders already do
it thank you very much alas good to have
you here